[موسيقى] يكتنف
الغموض بحيرة لوخ نيس في اسكتلندا منذ فترة طويلة مع تقارير عن
وحوش كامنة في أعماقها الحبرية
يعود تاريخها إلى العصور القديمة، وقد لفتت
انتباه العالم في ثلاثينيات القرن العشرين من خلال
سلسلة من المشاهدات المبلغ عنها
وصورة أيقونية، وبينما كانت قد تحولت  تبين
أنها واحدة من العديد من الخدع التي يواصل صائدو الوحوش
والسياح الفضوليون على حدٍ سواء
التوافد إليها منذ الآن
وبعد أكثر من 90 عامًا من الانبهار،
يمكنهم زيارة مركز جديد تبلغ تكلفته 1.9 مليون دولار
مخصص لكل ما يتعلق بوحش بحيرة لوخ نيس
بينما يرغب أولئك الذين يرغبون في الاقتراب
أكثر  يمكنك القيام برحلة على متن
سفينة أبحاث المسح العميق، التي قضت فيها Skipper alist
mat السنوات العشر الماضية في منح
الزائرين والباحثين أفضل
فرصة لاكتشاف
Nessie التي عملنا عليها في
السنوات الأخيرة، وقد قمنا هنا ببعض
المشاريع الكبيرة، أحدها  تضمنت تلك المشاريع
رسم خريطة للجزء السفلي من شبكة L،
والآن كنا نستخدم بعض المعدات الذكية جدًا
ونستخدم هذه المعدات، يمكنني أن
أؤكد لك كل ما فعلناه في الواقع للعثور على
الوحش l n، وهذا هو نفس الوحش الذي
وجدناه هنا جيدًا، ليس تمامًا، ليس تمامًا.
أنا خائف لأنه اتضح أنه
كان هذا، لذا فقد تم تصميمه بالفعل
لفيلم ولكن بالعودة إلى العالم الحقيقي،
سنبحر إلى منتصف
Lo، وستتمكن من رؤية حجم Lo
الآن وهو كبير إلى حد ما  يبلغ طول لو نيس
23 مترًا ولكن في المتوسط ​​يبلغ عرضها
ميلًا واحدًا فقط وهي
عميقة أيضًا، لذلك يبلغ عمقنا الآن 226 مترًا و
227 أقصى عمق، النقطة الحمراء الكبيرة التي
ستكون وحشنا خلال 10 سنوات
القيام بذلك ثلاث مرات على
مسبار الصدى في Big Red Dot والذي
سيكون أقرب لقاء لي مع
وحش بين عامي 2018 و2019،
ساعد المسح العميق في إجراء مسح للحمض النووي
للقفل في حين أن الكميات الكبيرة من الحمض النووي لثعبان البحر
التي عثر عليها تشير إلى وجود كائن أرضي أكثر.
تفسيرًا لذلك، لم يمنع Monster
Hunter Alan McKenna من تنظيم
أكبر عملية صيد للمخلوقات منذ 50 عامًا
في
أغسطس، حيث تمت دعوتنا لأكبر عدد ممكن من المتطوعين
للانضمام إلينا للقيام بعطلات
نهاية الأسبوع لمشاهدة السطح على القفل، كما
يمكنك تخيل ذلك  كم كنت متحمسًا لأننا كنا
نستخدم نظام هيدروفون وهو
في الأساس ميكروفون تحت الماء ولكننا
سمعنا هذه النبضات الأربعة المميزة التي
تفكر في الطريقة الوحيدة التي يمكنني من خلالها
وصفها لك، نحن لا نعرف ما
هي ولكننا لم نسجلها و  لقد
ذهبنا إلى تلك المنطقة ربما ست إلى ثماني
مرات خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع تلك ولم
نسمع تلك الضوضاء مرة أخرى، وربما لا
نعرف أبدًا ما إذا كان ذلك هو نيسي، لكن عدم وجود
أدلة ملموسة على مر السنين لم
يفعل الكثير لتخفيف الغموض، حيث أن
العديد من الأدلة القاطعة هي  ما
نريده دائمًا، أليس كذلك، نريد دائمًا أن نعرف نعم
أو لا في كل شيء عن الحياة، ليس فقط
الوحوش ولكن بالنسبة لي هناك لغز
هنا وهذا ما أؤمن به بشدة
[موسيقى]